children in kenya's northeast bony
forest that's on the border with somalia
returned to the classroom this week
after seven
years schools were forced to close there
because teachers weren't willing to work
in the area
after deadly attacks by the militant
group al-shabab now two's east africa
correspondent
mario muller and a colleague from the
german weekly magazine der spiegel got
rare access to the volatile region of
body forest
that's near lamu island where they
visited
one school
the only way we could get to these
remote villages
near the somali border is by sea the
trip over land
is too dangerous improvised landmines
are scattered along the
only road planted by ashabab
on the edge of bony forest kyungwe
primary school has finally reopened
kids are back seven years after
al-shabab attacked villagers in the area
farid kali is the head teacher and also
the only teacher here
also bob targets the government employee
including myself the moment you wake up
and you find yourself that you are okay
you thank god
so as you sleep because before you sleep
you pray to god
kale was the only teacher who dared to
come back here
every half an hour he switches classroom
teaching up to three classes at the same
time
taking care of around 100 school
[Music]
i'm alone at children moment so teaching
becomes a problem
it is so tiresome because i
have to teach after completing the
lesson i go to another class i teach i
come to the restaurant i go to another
class i teach
he has a lot to catch up on the children
are years behind in their education
but they have learned how to react when
they hear gunshots and they know
what al-shabab is i'm afraid of them
because they burn the camps
but now i'm happy to go back to school
to continue studying
many of the children's parents couldn't
afford to take them to another school
so most of them had to stay at home kids
are excited to be back at school
you can really get a sense of how
important education is for them
but just 20 kilometers down this road
this week an a shabbat explosive device
blew up a military vehicle
and killed at least two kenyan soldiers
the threat is so great that a military
base has been set up next to the school
60 border patrol offices protect the
school and its children
the officers are concerned that the
security situation
is deteriorating currently not safe
currently not safe maybe for those
six six months that i've been here i
think
this month is not good
a few days ago the military defended a
larger base from an attack by the
islamists
these men put their lives at risk to
protect the school
from being raided
[Music]
in 2014 al-shabab attacked a nearby
village
the militants looted hospitals and
burned down schools
then they started rounding up young men
for recruitment
they told me that they would drop me to
the ground slash my neck
that's what they said after they
captured me they
started interrogating me and threatened
to slaughter me
they asked if my religion was not islam
they got my identity from my id card
they confirmed
he was spared because of his faith now
with the military base in place
villagers feel more secure and the
military has even started helping the
kids
border patrol officers from next door
are stepping in as part-time teachers
one of them samuel guitar was even
trained to be a teacher
before joining the army i met the
teacher
i found him he was he was mean
a lot he has so many kids here to teach
and i find the burden which he holds i
have to assist him
at times yeah for the better of these
kids
while schools remain open samuel guitao
says educating the next generation will
strengthen the fight against terrorism